faith and persecution how to protect
religious freedom in the interview
cdu/csu parliamentary group leader
falkirk counter hakoda wound up mr.
Crowder hundreds of thousands of
Christians have left Iraq and Syria in
the past years and months almost every
day we hear reports about systematic
persecution expulsion even murder no one
reacts anymore in Europe how do you
explain that nie of y'all see anything
in that Cody shunran of course we see
these things and we find them deplorable
knock to deal with right now in the
German parliament we're talking about
Iraq and how we can take in more
refugees maybe I'll the German president
has spoken about it always look the
situation in Iraq is alarming because
the Islamist group Isis wants to
establish an Islamist State and the
Christians there are coming under
enormous pressure on Islam is a shot
elavil would decrease in command of
massive would be poked we have
information that Christians are being
forced to live under Sharia law and this
is all very alarming and terrible for
the people there siapa madison fatima
jinnah julie foy bow by these team are
very engaged with the situation of
persecuted Christians and other
minorities perhaps more than other
parliamentarians what's your motivation
the Bayan glow with us defly hide I
believe that the freedom is of the
utmost importance for humanity and
there's no freedom without freedom of
religion we see in many countries where
there's no religious freedom that other
kinds of freedom don't exist either
that's my motivation but I'm not solely
concerned about Christians I'm concerned
about freedom of religion but Christians
are the most persecuted religious group
I'm the peasant is a concern stem from a
pivotal personal experience or from your
role as a Christian Osceola's fungal
checklist be wounded notice is the show
980 modest me it's an issue that's
occupied me for many many years
it's been thrust into the four grams now
because despite everything that we
thought religion once again is playing a
hugely important role in global politics
that's bedok devilish beat vowel man in
light of the present conflict but also
20 years ago in the Balkans and other
conflicts of the past decades why do we
so often equate religion within
tolerance the marginalization of other
beliefs even violence why is that
Association so strong today associate
sahota and Faso Nylund no good viale for
Adam in mid Lebanon Middle East and
Africa especially we're seeing religious
groups caught up in political conflicts
in those places and in the Balkans we
saw the same thing the government isn't
able to maintain order and guarantee
people's safety the log is opting to
shafin see guide to God auntie LAN and
so we see persecution that's something
we have to take very seriously
unfortunately we can't seem to make any
progress on this issue at the United
Nations this Coleman Blvd sim tema in
the uno nicht richtig and and concrete
slunt Egypt is one country where you're
especially active the country's 8 to 10
million Coptic Christians continue to
suffer perhaps even more than ever
what's your personal experience they're
here in Berlin you often meet with
Egyptians and Coptic Christians Luke
optician cousin Kathy odds of the
coalition Krista Boehm Valley Coptic
Christians have had a very difficult
time it was especially hard when the
Muslim Brotherhood was in power at the
moment their situation has slightly
improved because the new president Abdel
Fattah al-sisi has brought more
stability and he's clamping down on
violence videl d divided cotton a bit of
a fluke woodman seat as we see in egypt
for democracy and freedom of religion to
flourish we need a stable political
conditions valve is stabilo for health
nice mid term agreement that very
argument the German government has been
exporting weapons too many of these
crisis regions for decades
but some of the main recipients of those
arms exports have been saudi arabia
algeria pakistan and indonesia those
countries are all in the top ten for
persecuting christians and restricting
religious freedoms but in top ten
anthemic oosten for fogo turkey is
received a large number of hand weapons
and even there Christians are killed
every few years doc doc Bobby it doesn't
make sense how can Germany criticize
other countries over human rights and
freedom of expression when those very
countries get their weapons from Germany
of the guards at soon fahad Ashton
Vuitton store and queen the most money
this land is lunch I'll detail you have
to look at each country individually
turkey is a NATO member and as such they
have a right to demand support that
includes support with weapons legalized
it built we have clear guidelines not to
deliver arms to so-called countries in
crisis but the term does not cover
freedom of religion to be a beneath the
gallant e de león's forehead Saudi
Arabia is not in crisis it's a stable
country but a country without religious
freedoms I think it's something we have
to pay more attention to but in the case
of Saudi Arabia it's a country that
contributes to maintaining stability in
the region this is I'll on this meat
stuff is all it does stability and
easily it's a counterbalance to the
power of Iran Iran Oh sleazy sometimes
there can be a sharp contradiction
between general political interests like
regional stability and the human right
to freedom of religion algemeine
politician interesting we stability in
diesel like y'all wouldn't dizzam
mention rate of hooligans find about us
ice tray out politically that's like
having to choose between the plague and
cholera countries like saudi arabia
qatar or Pakistan have handed out death
sentences to Christians yeah decides the
agenda gay oh that man's we have the
ongoing responsibility to press for
religious freedoms if all of those
countries guaranteed freedom of religion
Saudi Arabia Iran that would solve many
of the political problems
there wins on the UN Special Rapporteur
on freedom of religion or belief Heiner
bielefeld said that a main cause of
religious intolerance was massive
corruption massive corruption and
authoritarian rulers massive about
whatever should there be more political
action against corruption as a means of
bringing about more freedom of religion
with transport en una he invites fun
video feed is philly grief Teague Nevada
point made by mr. benefit is completely
correct I said myself that stable
political conditions go a long way
toward guaranteeing freedom of religion
corruption is not a stable political
condition which is as part of our
international cooperation and dialogue
we have to put more emphasis on good
governance guilds feel Ian bison on good
governance is an issue that belongs in
our development programs this all has to
play a more prominent role and I think
it's one of the reasons behind my own
activities wouldn't feel my any activity
that's been even when we talk openly
about freedom of religion as part of our
political dialogue then we can bring
about change bang couldn't below it was
for end on Isis concrete azim so does
that mean that the issue shouldn't just
be addressed by the develop minister but
by all the other ministers in their
negotiations as well for hunt room uses
timid under question zone mmm y'all
quite two o'clock tacos in quality
governments coalition agreement
specifically says that the issue of
freedom of religion is an integral part
of our value oriented foreign policy so
of course it has a place the issue has
to be at the center of our political
discourse in middle political discussion
leggy field well up in whether it's
terrorism in Syria Iraq Africa or in the
Middle East the discussion always
revolves around Islam and radical Islam
that includes the debate over jihadist
fighters returning to Germany from Syria
does the rise of terrorism frighten you
from a religious perspective that was oh
I know
reduce incited angst angst assimilative
at cable and I fear is always a bad
advisor see I'm not frightened by the
development but I am very concerned it
has to be said because you can only
change things when you tell the truth
right now radical Islam is the greatest
threat to religious freedom bothell lady
Goins fight has given rise to militant
groups that are spreading terror across
entire regions oh LOL golden at the
Meech they can gan say league yona new
booty and we may see that in iraq and
also in nigeria with Boko Haram what's
happening there is unspeakable yeah
safely massive up what do you expect
from Muslims in Germany wife advice
you've often pointed out they have
nothing to do with those Islamist groups
and some of them unjustly detained mmm
the ability to next to my touch diamond
us first of all I agree that Muslims
living in Germany have nothing to do
with the Islamists in Nigeria for
instance was by Smith YZ but it's still
my wish that members of other religious
groups give more support to the idea
that freedom of religion is an
inalienable human right Mickey Dunn and
reveal Igor's kopam when toasted soon by
the intima become dust by fleas but I'd
like to see a clear position from the
association of Muslims in Germany see
claw and decide to stay legal eagles fly
height east moon for oily his mention
late expected when you talk to experts
like hi Nabila felt we often hear that
dialogue is fundamental to halting
religious persecution dialogue between
religions but it organized discussions
we see politicians officials or experts
talking among themselves the dialogue
stays in a small circle what are they
doing wrong by me elokin Clank eyes of
us lifestar files algae club we showed
us discus play no 20 guests and does I
also believe that discussion is
necessary and in the public discourse in
Germany we should always emphasize the
issue of religious freedom it's a great
situation for Muslims in Germany that
they can practice their religion freely
and build
asks we should point that out moshi and
Bowen couldn't as much 120 feet in visor
but it's also clear that we can't fight
extremist organizations in Iraq and
Nigeria with dialogue alone in Iraq the
tribes and clans have links with the
Islamists became from Curtin amia lock
is naturally oh no soda stop the STEMI
yet still being dished m.a.c committed
in Islam is forbidden and Armas monsey
so I have to ask ourselves if Iran's
political leaders have always received
the best advice balada we have to pay
attention to that as well religion is
often instrumentalized to occupy
positions of power la paz it's your
little visits across our counter thank
you did you're welcome